alors aujourd'hui j'ai confondu quelque
chose dans ma préparation je m'attendais
pas du tout à cette lignée j'ai fait
tout de suite une énorme imprécisions
qui qui me force
enfin qui rend la position complètement
égal voilà après c'est le risque à
chaque fois dans cette position de se
retrouver attrapé dans une préparation
et de devoirs ferniot rapidement donc
forcément c'est pas un bon résultat mais
puis la manière n'y est pas mais au
moins ça peut même espérer me laisse
espérer récupérer pour demain pour les
tie break je pense que là évidemment y
ait quelque chose devait forcément se
passait à ce moment-là et et verra la
priorité c'est d'arriver reposé pour les
tie breaks
quand je reçois pas mal de messages pas
mal de de soutien depuis la france donc
forcément ça samad a aussi enfin
évidemment je me sens concerné même sens
même sans ça mais évidemment ça m'aide à
garder le moral puisque mon est
forcément trois semaines au même endroit
c'est toujours un peu ennuyeux et
forcément
j'aimerais bien d'un côté être en france
maintenant mais évidemment si proche du
budget j'ai pas envie de commander mon
ticket de retour si vite